there is an undeniable reality that if
Donald Trump follows through with the
campaign promise of dismantling
Obamacare the Affordable Care Act it is
going to be a disaster for not just
millions of people but millions of Trump
voters and then the question becomes
will Trump voters hold Trump accountable
for taking away their health insurance
but I don't want to get ahead of myself
let's sort of talk through it Donald
Trump campaigned very aggressively he
campaigned big league or big Li
whichever you prefer on repealing the
Affordable Care Act however then after
becoming the president-elect he met with
President Obama came out of that meeting
and said you know what there are some
Obamacare provisions that I like very
much but let's consider that he has put
together a very anti Obamacare a set of
advisors and cabinet members I told you
last week about Donald Trump's electing
Tom Price to lead the Health and Human
Services Department Secretary of Health
and Human Services
he is a major anti Obamacare guy who to
his credit at least authored something
that is a replacement for Obamacare
called the empowering patients first act
it's a disaster but at least it's
something
and whatever ends up taking the place of
Obamacare will cover fewer people and
economist Paul Krugman wrote about this
how many people might end up losing
coverage because of their election of
Donald Trump
the initial answer from Paul Krugman is
that somewhere between 3 and 1/2 million
and 4 million Trump voters would likely
lose health insurance if Donald Trump
indeed does what he promised to do greg
sargent from The Washington Post has
also written about this and he said
quote I have obtained new numbers from
the Gallup Healthways well-being index
that suggests that a lot of poor and
working-class whites who voted for Trump
and disproportionate numbers have
benefited from Obamacare meaning they
likely stand to lose out from its repeal
and even its replacement with something
that covers far fewer people so there's
no doubt that if Trump does what he
promised to do Trump voters millions of
them are going to lose health coverage
the real question is will they blame
Trump
I predict no Pat and why do I predict no
well just look at the experience we have
with Obamacare when Obamacare was
enacted there was this thing called the
state Medicaid expansion and states
could decide on their own either to
participate in the Medicaid expansion or
not to participate now it was really
cheap for States the federal government
subsidized most of the state cost for
doing that Medicaid expansion at least
in the medium term and many Republican
governors chose not to do it just a few
examples Alabama Georgia Florida Wyoming
South Dakota very long list the people
in those states without health care who
could have had it under the Medicaid
expansion aren't by and large angry with
their Republican governors they're angry
with Obama because quote Obamacare is a
disaster so we have experienced Pat we
know that when Republican governors make
the decision not to provide health care
to certain constituents that would get
it through the Medicaid expansion the
Republicans in those states don't blame
their governors by and large they blame
Obama and there's one other example
which is when Ronald Reagan busted the
air traffic controllers Union by
bringing in strike breakers this was a
big signal that this was going to be a
decline for American labor in the
American labor movement and that should
have led Heartland whites to vote
against Ronald Reagan in big numbers and
they did they ended up giving him a 49
state landslide not not long thereafter
so I predict and history tells us that
Trump voters will lose health insurance
because of Donald Trump and they will
blame it on I don't know some liberal
somewhere yeah I don't think there's any
reason why a trump supporter would
defect from Donald Trump he even said
himself he could shoot someone in the
middle of Fifth Avenue yeah and no one
would blame him he wouldn't lose any
voters this is just the latest example
of people voting against their own
interests because they're misinformed
yeah no doubt about it we've seen this
before and I think that it will not be a
political liability for Donald Trump
unless media actually gets it together
and calls Donald Trump's actions for
what they are we're going to be doing
that I can't speak for anybody else
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low used price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s